hello and welcome to this video explain to
you be simple and mighty culinary
aggression is and how to easily kitchen
led this online
can we get started right now and
regression analyzes love you too
products variable beast size to beautiful
variables
one question you can meet them  a
regression analyzes is wat influences
and persons ellory
in order to do this you could take the
highest indication that level
de weekly working hours and the age of
the person on the other hand you could
oost product en person salary based on
the higher education  my weekly
working hours and age de warm have you
want to predict is cold deep end end
variable cry tyrion the variable used to
predict the salary agreement
independent dairy levels of predictors
the iphone regression analyzes is use for
purposes while a bus is to measure the
influence  of one or more variables of
an old variable and the sec purpose is
to predict en variable taiwan morado
variables de simple l  ineaire gresham
uses only one independent where i have
to predict that deep and a variable in
december where we want to predict the
salary over perth
we use only one variable earth whether
one has studied at the weekly working
hours of the age pressed in malibu
linear crashing
several independent variables and use to
predict
that deep and jerry have zo week use the
highest educational level
the weekly working hours and the eight
drivers soda for the difrnce pietri
simple regression and the maisboeren
crash
is that in my case to crash your home that ben
and jerry's  cough and in that old case
muse several different
independent variables postform dust
regression have come on that the die pain
and jerry apple is with rick and in my
gravel for i sample the salary or
first the body size the shoe size or the
electric de  consumption in contrast
to the logistic regression issues
when lifting category cody ben and
jerry level
the just the progression is discussed in
t  he third video in this playlist
so summarized information
the simple linear gresham issues for
the crashing
that's the wiki working time heaven
influence on the old lee salary of
enfolies
there's only one in the page where ever
you switch is the weekly working time
the multitool linear  regression could be
used for the issue
doe de wiki working hours and the age of
angeles
haven influence on their all kinds of salary
ze in this case we heft toe in die ben
het vertes de wiki working hours and
the age of family leds for start with the
simple  linear regression
the goal of simple linear crashing is the
predictive value of the payment wearable
based on and independent wearable the
cries the linear read chippie trien
the independent variable nd ben and jerry
have is the moor accurate the
production give you a leader relationship
between de  variable scampi 3% the in
scepter flat
the cries the ruler relationship
between dependent and the independed
variable is the mo  there the did on us
lie on one straight-line the test of a
simple linear crash journalists who left
two poor jack the straight-line this
best described the linear lay's chips
showcase die piment and the independent
variable in the contexts flame your
grace and analyzes  and straight line is
flat the intercept plot to the tram
in the straight-line ruler regression
usedom s it of least squares
let's say hospital has a view to give
them and estimated based on the edge of
a person of hello the person will stay
in the  hospital after surgery with this
in most guests the operators because the
optima is the planning
you ben and jerry have the walls
walls product is simple for me to
finish the length of stay the surgery and jimmy
ben and jerry is age
de i knew that  describes the modern
looks like this
zo in this reason why it is the estimate
this length of stay
pi is the demolition ex is diet and
is the recipes point zo this is the
intercept had the white axis
zo de r  ecepten point has you that i
first sirius also
this person is in the
hospital in order to calculate the
provisions
de hospital must of course the us sample
of people of how you know the age and
the length of stay of the third street
as we  did you got you good for me
sample of always who is syrup online
for and is one point to this is such a
model and becomes this model
you can apps that girl the lens or stab
or the surgery
based on the edge of a person  like is
minimal
if you that there is a person who is
thirty-three here kind and is registered
for surgery
who put thirty-three forex already some form
of tessa de this person always
hoping to do for 5-point eat two days
after  surgery
nou of short question is how do you
look suffered the demolition be and how do you
calculate the intercept i usually i just
use and statistics program
like did it up in the case of a
simple linear gresham however it is
also quite simple watch members
patient  be  precise of the correlation of
the toe variables times the votes
deviation of the variable and
of staff the surgery the wider
palestinians deviation of age
hey is at the end pantry leadership the
mean well i use of the line
or two minors the demolition times the meme
value  of the age
de regression line with tries to match
the given day straight-line
sps possible of course this over is
fries as in one and stir this is cool
epsilon let's say who estimates the
length of stay up the surgery of person
who is  thirty three years old
all models elsa's de de fair and always
in the hospital for five points 2 days
but in fact
yoshi always in the hospital for seven
days dan met dat friend between the
estimated value and the true value is al
gore
now you have good  overview of what simple
remia progression is one of counteren
malibu linear grathem
in contrast to the simple linear
gresham the multiple linear crashing
canning close to a more independent
wearelabels
so i already  know the goal of a
regression is de estimé coercion variable
base decipher old variables de wario
go to the estimated is kotelet die ben
and jerry have of cry tyrion de rem
levels dat and used for production
agreement
indipendent variables of predictors
maar de boer junior regression is  often
used and empirical social research
texting market research in bol seriously
this is of great interest to find out
what in flange the friend often the disk
or types variable sw already know
this is what the equation for a simple
junior regression looks like i am  an
independent where we have x plus the
constant
final code way of malibu linear
regression
we have several independent variables
add who has the first where we have the
secondary and the case
variable the coefficient channel the intro
projet
similarly toe the linear crash which i
fall  in die pan and jerry levels as you
do we get their value
lief en in die pain and jerry have
changes by one unit
de correspo  nding proficiency in that time
at how much to deepen their label
changes before a show you how to
interpret the was as if a regression
april first explain how you can easily
watch suffered en linear crash and online
in order to this place with it tasted
app.net  and click under
too close just eat if you want to use
your date a chest league and cleo table
i'm going to use the example they channel
are au bon to watch late and
regression
sorry choose the tap grab
they could left right you can select  your
die ben and jerry cables and then right
side
you in die ben and jerry appels led cb van
two beste keet wat influences the
salary
zoey simply click and salary and let's
cs in lebanon variables
wie select chenda age
en know now scroll down who already
see the was as if the linear crash in the
vest able to see the module summary in the
bag and table
wie sie dann nova in the sir table week
and see how the coefficient
if you like you can click on summer i in
words and chat d  e interpretation of
fill three sets if you want to check the
conditions for your regression model you
can click on check conditioner is you
want to know more about that you will
find another video
certain conditions in all playlist
nolita deepened and slow curry sauce
in the molds summary  you find mit bill
correlation coefficient ar disco efficient
girls the relationship of correlation
between er deep and it where we have and
the independent wearelabels in order to
find out how much of the variants of the
deep and and two we have issacs plant
jesse sign counter de ar  square order
extreme variance
and other important in die chain is the
just sittard squire
the x-axis this ar square is important
because a square over s teammates the
coefficient or determination of my
die in that am again labels to use
and finally
in the  model summary it's important to
look the standard estimation euro the
standard estimation there at that time
by how much the modal over s teammates
de di  e pain and variable an average in
a bag and table
you find so the so tap validation
you and f test is provided which test had the
name balmatten
what is the variance explanation arr square
in the population iroh
in general diskettes of van distress of such
great  interest
the test is equivalents sorting that already
closed professions in the population
azzaro de nek stable is of great importance
picacho stars gresham proficiency in
this table
you find whether the in deep and network cables
the on adams proficiency the stunned
guys professions betta
the standard there on this  intp value
de on stunned guys professions be an
important for de regression aggression
de stunned guys professions beta ar
important for the integration of the way
as big as you can compare them to each
other for example de recyko dat age 60
greatest in flens ons ellery lucas  age
as the highest paid to coefficient
further it is important to look at the
pain when you
de key values ​​as you if you're a
profession  sar significant need is the
values ​​as mill dance europe our year
or five
you can consider your glofiish and test
significant
so become your favorite no other
requirements for and regression models
if you want to know about your
requirements for regression
please watch my next video